Now, let's get a little bit more work done with some adjacency matrices,
just so you can get a bit more comfortable.
So let's talk about inverse graphs.
In the unit, we discussed how to create the inverse graph as a graph
that helps us solve the clique problem.
So, for example, the inverse graph of the graph that I drew before would be the graph
with the red edges here, so quite a different graph here.
Now, how do you represent this as an adjacency matrix.
Well, to diagnose is the because we're not allowing loops anywhere in here, so the diagnose to 0's,
and you know when once we have in the adjacency matrix are from the D to A or from A to D
so the matrices is symmetric and from B to D and everything else is 0--
means that all of these edges disappear in the inverse graph.
Now, how do you represent this in Python.
Well, an easy way to represent a matrix in Python is as a list of list,
so to look at some output of some code,
we define a completely empty graph here. Now, we print the graph we see.
But this is just a list of list with five 0's in our list, and if we invert this graph,
when we see that we get the graph of all 1's except for the diagonal here
of course since we don't have any loops.
So what I want you to do is write an inverse graph function such that it takes a graph
or a list of list and outputs a list of list, which is the inverse of the input graph.